GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A BIG
DECISION TO MAKE.
WILL THE U.S. RETALIATE AGAINST
SYRIA.
BASHAR AL-ASSAD, ACCUSED OF
USING POISON GAS AGAIN ON HIS
OWN PEOPLE.
>> IT WAS AN ATROCIOUS ATTACK.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
YOU DON'T SEE THINGS LIKE THAT
AS BAD AS THE NEWS IS.
YOU DON'T SEE THOSE IMAGES.
WE ARE STUDYING THAT SITUATION
EXTREMELY CLOSELY.
WE ARE MEETING WITH OUR MILITARY
AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
WE WILL BE MAKING SOME MAJOR
DECISIONS OVER THE NEXT 24 248
HOURS.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED WHEN A
THING LIKE THAT CAN HAPPEN.
THIS IS ABOUT HUMANITY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HUMANITY.
IT CAN'T BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT PUTTING
RUSSIA AND IRAN ON NOTICE,
SUGGESTING THEY MAY HAVE PLAYED
A ROLE AND COULD FACE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES AS WELL.
>> YOU MAY.
HE MADE.
IF HE DOES, IT'S GOING TO BE
VERY TOUGH.
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO PAY A
PRICE.
HE WILL.
EVERYBODY WELL.
>> U.S. MILITARY ACTION, IS IT
OFF THE TABLE?
>> NOTHING IS OFF THE TABLE.
>> Dana: THE ATTACK REPORTEDLY
KILLED 40 PEOPLE, COMES A YEAR
AFTER THE U.S. RETALIATED FOR
THE LAST SYRIAN GAS MASSACRE.
AN EMERGENCY SECURITY COUNCIL
MEETING HELD THE UNITED NATIONS
THIS AFTERNOON, GREG, PEOPLE
WONDERING IF THE UNITED NATIONS
PUT ANYTHING INTO THIS ACTION.
THE ATTACK CAME AT THE BREAKDOWN
OF TALKS BETWEEN ASSAD AND THE
REBELS.
>> Greg: THE TIMING IS SO
WEIRD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS WE ARE
PULLING OUT AND A CHEMICAL
ATTACK PRESENTS ITSELF WHICH
KIND OF SAYS NOT YET.
THEY ARE SMART PEOPLE, SMARTER
THAN ME ON THIS, WHO BELIEVE
SYRIA IS BEHIND THIS.
TOM ROGAN WROTE A PIECE TODAY.
SENATOR McCAIN.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME
FOR TWO REASONS.
SYRIA CAN'T HIDE FROM
RETRIBUTION.
CLEARLY THEY ARE, IF THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE, THEY WILL BE
BOMBED.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY CAN RUN TO
THE MOUNTAINS.
IF YOU WANT AMERICA TO LEAVE,
WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS?
MAYBE I'M NOT THAT BRIGHT BUT
ASIDE FROM THAT, WE ARE STILL
GOING TO RETALIATE.
THE REASON WHY WE ARE GOING TO
RETALIATE IS BECAUSE ASSAD IS
LIKE O.J. SIMPSON.
O.J. DIDN'T GET FOUND GUILTY OF
HIS REAL CRIMES OF KILLING
NICOLE AND RON BRADY WAS FOUND
GUILTY OF A LATER CHARGE FOR
ARMED ROBBERY AND KIDNAPPING.
THE FACT IS ASSAD HAS DONE
ENOUGH BAD STUFF THAT IF HE
DIDN'T DO THIS, SO WHAT.
>> Dana: PERHAPS ASSAD SAYS
THE BENEFIT OF VICTORY
OUTWEIGHS --
>> Jesse: HE IS ON HIS HEELS.
I DON'T BELIEVE HE WOULD DO THIS
WITHOUT RUSSIA'S KNOWLEDGE.
THEY ARE THE SPONSOR AND PUPPET
MASTER.
TRUMP WAS HANDED A MESS IN
SYRIA.
THAT'S NOT MY COMMENT.
THAT'S OBAMA'S NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL SPOKESMAN WHO SAID THAT
HIMSELF THE OTHER DAY.
HERE'S WHY.
ONE OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT, THERE
WAS A BIG LEADERSHIP VACUUM IN
THE REASON.
RUSSIAN CAME IN TO FILL IT.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE CIVIL
WAR, THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SPENT HALF A BILLION DOLLARS TO
TRAIN FIVE SYRIAN REBEL
FIGHTERS.
IT WAS A WASTE FROM THE JUMP.
THEN YOU HAVE THIS INCREDIBLE
GAS ATTACK WHERE OBAMA DREW A
REDLINE, DIDN'T RESPOND.
PUTIN HAD TO SWEEP AND HELP
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAVE FACE AND
ORGANIZED THIS GROUP TO RID
SYRIA OF THESE CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
PEOPLE LIKE JOHN KERRY AND SUSAN
RICE BRAGGED ABOUT BRINGING ALL
THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS OUT OF
THERE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HIMSELF SAID IT
WAS THE CROWNING ACHIEVEMENT OF
ITS FOREIGN POLICY LEGACY.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY IN TATTERS NOW.
IT DIDN'T HELP SENDING ALMOST
$2 BILLION IN CASH TO THE
IRANIANS.
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE A PROXY WAR,
AND IT'S PROBABLY TRIBAL.
IT BRINGS IN THE GREAT POWERS,
AMERICA AND RUSSIA, BUT YOU HAVE
THE SAUDIS AND THE IRANIANS
GOING AT IT BECAUSE THERE IS A
MAJOR NATURAL GAS PIPELINE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE TRYING TO
REROUTE IT TO THE EUROPEAN UNION
REROUTE IT TO THE EUROPEAN UNIO
EUROPEAN UNION.
RUSSIA HAS THIS PORT CITY THAT
GIVES ITS NAVY ACCESS TO THE
MEDITERRANEAN.
THEY HAVE AN AIR BASE WITH ABOUT
1,000 PERSONNEL.
SYRIA ALLOWS THE IRANIAN NAVY
ACCESS TO THE MEDITERRANEAN.
IT LOOKS LIKE OUR SIDE, THE
SAUDIS, ISRAELIS, OUR REBELS.
THEY ARE GETTING DESPERATE.
PUTIN IS PROBABLY HEARD FROM
THAT SANCTIONS AND HIS OLIGARCH
FRIENDS ARE HURTING AND ENERGY
PRICES ARE LOW AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO TEST OUR RESOLVE.
I BELIEVE YOU CAN SEE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SEETHING WHEN HE
IS CROSSING HIS ARMS LIKE THAT.
THE LAST TIME HE DID THAT WAS
THE "FIRE AND FURY" COMMENT.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO PAY,
LIKE HE SAID, STEEP PRICE.
>> Dana: EVERY MAJOR PLAYERS
THERE.
OUR WESTERN ALLIES.
RUSSIAN, IRAN, PERHAPS
NORTH KOREA.
WE KNOW NORTH KOREA HAD BEEN
HELPING SYRIA BEFORE WITH
NUCLEAR MATERIAL AND POSSIBLY
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
ALSO ISRAEL.
WHEN THE ATTACK STARTED
HAPPENING IN SYRIA LAST NIGHT,
THE UNITED STATES SAID IT'S NOT
US.
EVERYBODY IS SAYING IT'S NOT US.
AND SAUDI NOT COMPLAINING THAT
ISRAEL TOOK ACTION.
>> Juan: IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND ISRAEL
DECIDED THEY COULD TAKE
UNILATERAL ACTION.
IT'S BECAUSE THE UNITED STATES
IS THERE TO BACK THEM UP.
IN A SENSE, IT IS ISRAEL ACTING
IN A WAY THAT WOULD HELP THE
UNITED STATES AND ALLOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP MORE TIME TO
DECIDE WHAT'S APPROPRIATE
ACTION.
I THINK IT'S TELLING THAT IT WAS
A YEAR AGO HE SAID ASSAD WAS NOT
A PRIORITY FOR HIM AND THAT'S
WHEN ASSAD DID THE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS ATTACK.
THIS TIME IT WAS HIS REMARKS IN
OHIO LAST WEEK SAYING IT'S TIME
TO GET OUT OF SYRIA.
NOW THEY ACT AGAIN.
IT LOOKS LIKE WHENEVER THERE'S A
SIGN FROM THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
THAT MAYBE WE ARE NOT PAYING
FULL ATTENTION, ASSAD THEN SEES
IT AS A SIGNAL FOR HIM TO TAKE
ACTION.
HE CAN DO WHAT HE WANTS TO DO.
TO ME, THIS IS VERY TROUBLING
BECAUSE IT OPENS THE DOOR NOT
ONLY TO RUSSIA AND IRAN BUT ALSO
ISLAMIC STATE COMING BACK INTO
THE PICTURE.
IT'S NOT, IF NOT ISLAMIC STATE,
THAN AL QAEDA.
DON'T FORGET THE TALIBAN IS
RIGHT NEXT DOOR.
>> Dana: KIMBERLY, THE THING
THAT IS SO DISGUSTING ABOUT
ASSAD IS HIS WILLINGNESS TO
ATTACK CHILDREN.
OUT OF THESE 40 THAT WERE
KILLED, MANY OF THEM WERE
CHILDREN.
CHILDREN AND INNOCENTS ARE DYING
BY LOTS OF OTHER MEANS AS WELL
BUT CHEMICAL WEAPONS, IS NOT
GOING TO BE OUR REDLINE?
>> Kimberly: IT SHOULD BE.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME
AGO.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO SHOW HIS
RESOLVE IN HIS STRENGTH, THAT HE
WILL NOT TOLERATE THESE KIND OF
ATROCITIES AND THE GENOCIDE
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON THERE.
THIS GUY IS JUST DISGUSTING,
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS, LACK OF ANY
KIND OF MORALITY OR HUMANITY TO
MURDER CHILDREN IN THIS WAY.
OBVIOUSLY ISRAEL STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE.
THEY HAVE THE BACKING OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I THINK THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE THE COURSE OF
HISTORY IN THAT REGION WHICH IS
SO FRAUGHT WITH SO MANY PROBLEMS
IN TERMS OF THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE REGION, POLITICALLY AND
OTHERWISE.
THIS IS GOING TO SAY A LOT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS PRESIDENCY,
HIS HANDLE ON FOREIGN AFFAIRS
AND NATIONAL SECURITY.
HE HAS SHOWN THE STRENGTH
BEFORE.
IT HAS WORKED.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO RESPOND
RATHER QUICKLY IN REGARDS TO
THIS.
>> Greg: CAN I RESPOND TO ONE?
WHEN SOME BIG BAD GUY LEAVES AT
BARNEY'S GOING TO LEAVE A BAR,
YOU DON'T THROW SOMETHING AT THE
GUY AS HE'S LEAVING, YOU JUST
HOPE HE LEAVES.
WHAT YOU SAID WAS THAT TRUMP
SAYING THAT SIGNALED ASSAD THERE
WAS A LACK OF ATTENTION AND
THEREFORE HE COULD TAKE HIS OWN
ACTION.
WHY WOULDN'T HE JUST DO NOTHING
AND LET THE BIG GUY LEAVE?
>> Dana: TO REEMPHASIZE, WHAT
HAPPENED ON FRIDAY WAS THAT THE
TALKS BETWEEN ASSAD AND THE
REBELS BROKE DOWN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WAS
CAUSATION OR CORRELATION OR
WHATEVER, BUT THERE WAS AN
ACTION IN SYRIA THAT MAYBE THEY
WEREN'T PAYING ATTENTION OF WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS SAYING.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY WERE
PAYING ATTENTION TO TRUMP.
I THINK FOR THEM, THE
UNITED STATES, THE BIG GUY
ONCE YOU SEE THE BIG GUY AT WALK
AWAY, FOR ASSAD, IT WAS THIS IS
MY COUNTRY.
THIS IS WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
SAID.
ASSAD IS THE LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT OF SYRIA.
HE SAYS TO TRUMP YOU CAN'T TALK
AND ACT TO A LEGITIMATELY
ELECTED PRESIDENT IN THIS WAY.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP THEN SAID TO
PUTIN, WHO IS OFTEN TIMES, YOU
KNOW, RELUCTANT TO CRITICIZE,
YOU ARE WRONG.
I WAS REALLY STRUCK BY THAT.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY MUST
HAVE INTEL BUT TELL THEM.
THEY KNOW, RUSSIA, 119 MILLION
PEOPLE OR SOMETHING.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT IS TRYING
TO MAKE SOME SORT OF INVESTMENT
IN ASSAD AND THEY MADE A REALLY
BAD BET IN HIM.
BUT NOW YOU HAVE THIS SEETHING
CAULDRON, AS KIMBERLY WAS
SAYING, THE GEO-COMPLEXITIES, IT